WELCOME TO THE AUGUST TWENTY
FIRST APPROPRIATIONS HEARING
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS HEARING
WE HAVE NINETY ONE BILLS TO
CONSIDER THIS MORNING SO I WILL
ALWAYS APPRECIATE IT WHEN WE
WAY PRESENTATION ON A SUSPEND
SPELL. BUT OF COURSE THAT IS UP
TO THE AUTHOR. WE NOTING THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM WILL GO
AHEAD AND START AS EIGHTY. SUB
COMMITTEE. MR HERTZBERG IT
LOOKS LIKE MISTER BELL I DIDN'T
SEE YOU THERE. MISTER BELL. MR
BILL'S GOING TO BE PRESENTING
ON A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SB FIVE.
MISTER BELL
. RIGHT WHEN YOU ARE
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS SB FIVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INVESTMENT PROGRAM AND WE'RE
PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS BILL
THIS MORNING. AND SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTIES
CALIFORNIA HAS FAILED TO
PRODUCE THE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND HOUSING UNITS. NEEDED
TEACHER TO MEET THE DEMAND FOR
A STATE. AS A RESULT WE ARE IN
THE MIDST OF A HISTORIC.
HOMELESS AND HOUSING CRISIS
BOTH NEARLY HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
ARE LIVING ON OUR STREETS LAST
YEAR. THIS BILL IS BEFORE IT
MAKES THE STATE A LONG TERM
FINANCIAL PARTNER. TO THE CITY
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MERELY
PARTNER AND CONSTRUCT
DESPERATELY NEEDED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. FOR HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIANS IT HELPS RELIEVE
POVERTY CREATE JOBS MEETS OUR
STATE WIDE ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
WITHOUT AFFECTING OUR SCHOOL
FUNDING. NOW ACCORDING TO AN
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS PREPARED BY
CARPENTERS REGIONAL COUNCIL IN
THE CALIFORNIA IN PARTNERSHIP.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE EIGHTY
SIX THOUSAND NEW AND RE AND
REHABILITATED HOUSING BILLS.
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND JOBS AND SPUR MORE
THAN SIXTY BILLION. AND.
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY OVER A TEN
YEAR PERIOD. THE BILL RESPONDS
TO THE NEEDS OF SIT AND
COUNTIES AND PROVIDE STATE
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE FUNDS ARE
USE QUICKLY AND EFFECTIVELY TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROMOTE TRANSIT OR IN
DEVELOPMENT ADDRESS IT ALSO
ADDRESS IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. FUNDS CAN BE USED ONLY
ON PROJECTS APPROVED BY STATE
COMMITTEE AT LEAST 50% OF ALL
FUNDING MUST BE USED TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IT
COMPLEMENTS THE LEGISLATIVE
INVESTMENTS IN SHORT TERM
HOUSING BY PROVIDING ONGOING
FUNDING FOR LONG TERM FOR A
LONG TERM SOLUTION HOUSING
CRISIS THE BILL ALIGNS WITH
OTHER STATE. AND FEDERAL
PROGRAMS TO ENSURE GOVERNMENT'S
LEVERAGE ADDITIONAL NON STATE
GENERAL FUNDS THE STATE BUDGET
IS ALSO PROTECTED. THIS BILL
SETS UP A STRUCTURE FOR THE
PROGRAM IN A ZERO FISCAL IMPACT
UNTIL THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE ALLOCATE FISCAL
AUTHORITY IN THE IN THE BUDGET.
WHAT'S THE FINANCING IS
AUTHORIZE THE STATE CANCERS.
FURTHER PROJECT APPROVALS
DURING ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST CONFIRMED
IN WRITING THERE WILL BE NO
NEGATIVE IN FISCAL IMPACT ON
SCHOOLS THE STATE IS REQUIRED
TO BACK FILL SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES UNDER PROP
NINETY EIGHT. THIS TIME I TURN
OVER TO MY WITNESSES SAYS OUR
TIAS FROM THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
DAVID SANDER VICE MAYOR OF
RANCHO CORDOVA IF YOU CAN HOLD
FOR JUST ONE MOMENT I'M SORRY
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SECRETARY
GONZALEZ BIGELOW BLOOM BONTA
BROUGH CALDERON CREEL CHAO DEEP.
EGGMAN FONG HERE GABRIEL GARCIA
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK HERE RIVAS.
WITHOUT WILL GO TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY OF COURSE YOU WILL
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS UNDER TWO
MINUTES AND ONLY DEAL WITH
FISCAL ISSUES. THANK YOU. MY
NAME IS DAVID SANDER I AM VICE
MAYOR OF THE CITY VENTURED OVER
RIGHT HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA I SERVE ON THE BOARD TO
LEAVE CALIFORNIA CITIES I'VE
ALSO BEEN A BOARD MEMBER THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE OF CITIES AND I
AM CURRENTLY HONOR TO BE THE
FOUR CHAIR FOR SAY COG. THE COG
HERE IN THE AN MPO HERE IN THE
SACRAMENTO REGION I'D SAY CUT
WE ARE TAKING VERY SERIOUSLY
THE STATE'S MANDATE TO IMPROVE
OUR GREENHOUSE GAS SITUATION
AND WE KNOW WE NEED TO DO THAT
BY FINDING ALTERNATIVES TO
LEAPFROG DEVELOPMENT. OUR
ANALYSIS IS CLEARLY SHOWN THAT
WE CAN DO THAT TO INFILL
DEVELOPMENT BUT THERE ARE
SERIOUS BARRIERS TO INFILL
DEVELOPMENT NOT JUST IN OUR
REGION BUT EVERY JURISDICTION
IN THE STATE WE ALL HAVE OLD
COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS THE
LARGELY VACANT PROPERTIES THEY
WERE ONCE PROCESS. NOW NOT
PROSPEROUS AND THE MEANS OF
GETTING THOSE TO A PROSPEROUS
INFILL SITUATION IS CHALLENGED
BY INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES I WILL
GIVE YOU A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE ON
FULL SYMBOL OF ART IN RANCHO
CORDOVA WE AT A RESTAURANT TOUR
WHO WANTED TO GO INTO AN OLD
RESTAURANT LOCATION. HE APPLIED
EVERYONE WAS A FAVOR THE CITY
WAS IN PORT RAN INTO A PROBLEM
WITH THE SEWER DISTRICT WHERE
HE HAD TO IMPROVE THE OLD
GREASE TRAP FROM THE PREVIOUS
RESTAURANT UPDATED CURRENT
VERSION HE RAN INTO TROUBLE
WITH MUD THE ELECTRICITY
PROVIDER. AT A CERTAIN SIZE
TRANSFORMER THEY WANTED A NEWER
ONE YOU WERE UNDER THE RIGHT.
I'M WITH EIGHTY. HE WAS A GROUP
OFTEN THE PITCH. RAN INTO. THE
DRAINAGE SYSTEM IT WAS NOT OUR
NEED TO BE UPDATED TO THE NEW
STANDARDS ALL OF THESE THINGS
ADDED TOGETHER ADDED IN THE
DOLLARS TO THE COST OF HIS
PROJECT SO WHAT IT USED TO DO
WHAT ANY BUSINESS PERSON WHAT
HE WANTS TO THE NEW SIDE OF
TOWN. BUILT AS RESTAURANT WE
LOST AN OPTION FOR INFILL THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD LOS AN ASSET AND
PEOPLE ARE DRIVING FURTHER TO
GET TO THAT RESTAURANT. THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW US TO INTERVENE
IN THAT SITUATION AND MAKE
THOSE TO LICENSE ECONOMIC FOR
OUR RESIDENTS SO IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN A FOR. HOUSING OR
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT. OR IN
SUPPORTING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
ALL OF WHOM HAVE THESE OLD
COMMERCIAL CORRIDORS. THIS BILL
GIVES US A FINANCING MECHANISM
A MEANS OF PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT. YOU
TO ACCOMPLISH THOSE GOALS THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE BILL. NO NO
NO. THANK YOU IT'S- GOING TO
SUSPENSE. THANK YOU. MR DAYS
YOU CAN KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO
THE FISCAL ANALYSIS I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF. YOU GOT MY DAUGHTER
SHAS YEAH I ONLY PASSED FOR THE
DAY YEAH DEVICE BASICALLY THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES HOUSING
POLICIES ON ALL THOSE HAVE A
FISCAL COST TO THE STATE. THIS
BRINGS TOGETHER IN ONE WAY TO
ACTUALLY CREATE THAT SORT OF
IMPACT TO LOOK AT CLIMATE
CHANGE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
ARE ALSO ACROSS THE STATE IN
THE LONG TERM BUT ALSO CREATING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
WHILE CREATING GOOD PAYING JOBS
WHICH POSSIBLE VICE RELIEF FROM
THE GENERAL FUND BECAUSE YOU'RE
ACTUALLY CREATING JOBS THAT.
OUR FAMILY SUSTAINING AND. NOT
DEPENDENT ON GENERAL FROM
PROGRAMS WITH THOSE REASONS WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NOW WE'RE JUST GOING TO
EXPORTER'S NAME ORGANIZATION IN
POSITION. YES GOOD MORNING
STEVE CREWS FOR THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE AND SUPPORT. CASEY IT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
CUPERTINO LAFAYETTE A TRAVEL IS
IN SUPPORT. ENTER INTO A ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND THE SAN MATEO COUNTY
TRANSIT DISTRICT ON SUPPORT.
SALINAS POLICE SHAUN BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT. G. ON THE CITY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. JONATHAN
CLAIMED AFTER THE CITY AND
SENATORS AND SUPPORT. MIKE
MONOGRAM BEHALF OF THE SITTING
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IN THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT. MORE
DILATORY NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CARPENTERS REGIONAL COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. A STEVE ALL COMING UP
THE ON MEDICARE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION AND ENOUGH ABOUT
CONSTRUCTION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. SACRAMENTO THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS IN SUPPORT.
ROSS BUT THE ON THE OFFICE
SACRIFICE TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO AMERICA STEINBERG
AND SUPPORT. UNDERESTIMATE AS
ON BEHALF NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. MATT
REGAN WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. HOLDING MY CHILD
THEY HAVE FOR THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD IN SUPPORT. JUST
RANDOMLY CALIFORNIA CITIES IN
SUPPORT. AMY BROWN ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF LONG BEACH WAS
SACRAMENTO I NAPA AND SAN
CARLOS IN SUPPORT. CHRISLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. MORNING MANAGER MARK
LYNSKEY CITY OF ROSEVILLE IN
SUPPORT. SANDY GEORGE WITH
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. JULIE SNYDER
REPRESENTING HOUSING
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. JOHN
MOFFITT CITY OF US A IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT AT IT OKAY. CHRIS
ROSE ON BEHALF OF THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION. AGAIN WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO KEEP THESE COMMENTS TO
FISCAL THANK YOU IN TWO MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
JENNIFER BAKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE ARE UNFORTUNATELY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE DUE
TO THE FISCAL IMPACT THAT THIS
COULD HAVE ON OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. WERE CONCERNED FOR
TWO REASONS NUMBER ONE THIS
PUTS FISCAL PRESSURE ON THE
GENERAL FUND IT'S NOT A MAJOR
ISSUE RIGHT NOW AS WE ARE IN
RELATIVELY PAUSE POSITIVE
ECONOMIC TIMES WHAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS IN THE LONG
TERM IF WE WERE HEAD TO HEAD
INTO ANOTHER. SESSION AND WE
SEE ANOTHER SUSPENSION OF PROP
NINETY EIGHT THAT WOULD MEAN
THAT THE FUNDS THAT WE WOULD
HAVE RECEIVED OR PROP NINETY
EIGHT TO BE BACK TILL GENERAL
FUND MAY NOT MATERIALIZE IN
THAT COULD BE DEVASTATING FOR
THE- DISTRICT. PORTION
ALLIANCE. ON PROPERTY TAX FUNDS
WHEN TIMES ARE TOUGH AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR
BOB NAY WERE REPRESENTING FEELS
SAID IN COMPANY ON THE FISCAL
THIS IS THE EQUIVALENT OF A
THIRTY BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
OBLIGATION BOND ISSUES WHICH
MEANS THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS
PLUS INTEREST AND YOU CAN'T.
CUT THAT DOWN IN BAD ECONOMIC
TIMES SO CUTS AND OTHER
PROGRAMS INCLUDING EDUCATION.
NOW AS A NAME IN ORGANIZATION
POSITION ELIZABETH ASK OF ALL
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION I REQUEST THAT
THE BILL BE AMENDED TO NOT USE
THAT YOU ROUGH FUNDS. THANK YOU.
MUCH WITH THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT OPPOSE
UNLESS AMEND THAT AS WELL THANK
YOU. CHARLIE DAM UP ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION AND RAWSON OPPOSE
LIST AMENDED FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU I'M. DEPARTMENT
FINANCE I'M SORRY. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO KNOW ME ASSURE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL AT
THIS TIME WE NOTE THE BILL
ALLOWS LOCAL AGENCIES TO DIRECT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR AND EDUCATIONAL REVENUE
AUGMENTATION FUNDS BETWEEN JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
SIX AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
BETWEEN JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SIX AND JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY THIRTY
BECAUSE THE RAF OF SAYS THE
STATE'S PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND COSTS ON A DOLLAR
FOR DOLLAR BASIS THE BILL
CREATES A TOTAL PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND COST. OF UP
TO TWO BILLION DOLLARS. THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
IT WILL NEED TWENTY POSITIONS.
AND APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. AND ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT IN THE PROGRAM'S FIRST
YEAR. AND THREE POINT EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR
THEREAFTER. OF THE BILLS
ENACTED. ANY HD IT'S CITY
RESOURCES AND- RESOURCE NEEDS
WILL BE CONSIDERED AS PART OF
THE ANNUAL BUDGET DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS. OF FINANCES I BELIEVE
THIS WILL CREATE A REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE. THANK YOU AS
SENATOR BELL. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE FORCES BILL'S GOING THANK
YOU. APPRECIATE THE TIME THE-
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS ARE REFERRED
TO EARLIER. THAT WAS DONE
ACTUALLY ESTIMATED IN TERMS OF
STATE AND LOCAL TAX COLLECTION
OVER THE SAME TO IN YOUR PERIOD
TWO POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
IN TAXES THIS WILL BE. I THINK
ENOUGH TO OFFSET THE COST TO
THE DEPARTMENT SO I I'M I'M
HOPEFUL THAT YOU WILL HAVE TIME
TO READ THAT CONSIDER THE
ECONOMIC TO AND TAX FISCAL
IMPACT. FROM THAT STANDPOINT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
IT'S HARD. MR HERTZBERG I'M
ASSUMING YOU'RE GONNA WAVE
SUSPENSE ON OUR WAY
PRESENTATION YOUR SUSPENSE
BILLS AND PRESENT ON SB TWO TWO
NINE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THAT ASSUMPTION
IS CORRECT MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MS CREEL IN A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK. LAST
YEAR I DID A WHISTLE BLOWER
BILL THIS MAKES SOME TECHNICAL
CORRECTIONS TO MAKE THE BILL
BETTER ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE. SEE NO
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS
RELIABLE. THANK YOU. THAT GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR
DFO DEAN AYE THANK YOU. WAIT
START MISTER HERTZBERG MISTER
HILL. IF YOU IF YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE WAY PRESENTATION ON YOUR
SUSPENSE BILLS AND START WITH
SB FIVE FIFTY EIGHT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR SB FIVE FIFTY
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL CRITERIA
FOR THE SB FOR THE STADIUM YOU
SEE TO CONSIDER IN REVIEWING A
PROPOSED CORPORATE
RESTRUCTURING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK AND I BOTH. A MOTION. BY
MISTER OBERNOLTE A SECOND BY
MISS EGGMAN SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
NEUTRAL. SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THAT ACCOUNT.
THANK YOU MISTER HILL SB SIX
TWENTY FIVE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SB SIX TWENTY FIVE IS A
LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW MAKES
IT LEGAL FOR PASSENGERS OF
SMOKING CANNABIS BILLS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION
MEMBERS CRASHED RIVAL MEMBERS.
VERY MUCH TO CALLED AROUND
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT. SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
ANTICIPATES IT'LL CREATE A
FISCAL IMPACT OF FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME TO UPDATE
LITERATURE AND TRAINING
POLICIES AND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING TO
COMPLETE THE INSPECTIONS OTHER
WITH STATE STAFF OR BY
CONTRACTING THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION HAS
REGULAORY AND SAFETY OVERSIGHT
OVER THE FOR HIRE PASSENGER
CARRIERS WELL THE BILL NOT
SPECIFICALLY CREATE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS INITIATED A RESULT OF
THIS BILL REQUIRE HIGH HEARING.
COVER BASED ON THE LIMITED
NUMBER OF VEHICLES THAT MEET
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS THE
COMMISSION BELIEVES IT IS
UNLIKELY THAT THERE WILL BE A
SIGNIFICANT CASELOAD BUREAU OF
CAMPUS. CONTROL INDICATE ANY
FISCAL IMPACT FROM THE SCHOOLS
MINOR AFFORDABLE. ALL RIGHT.
WITH THAT ISRAEL. THANK YOU MAY
MERIT CHURCH WHEN TO MAKE TWO
POINTS ONE THERE IS OPPOSITION
FROM THE HIGHWAY PATROL LISTED
WE AMENDMENTS THAT WE WILL BE
TAKING AFTER THIS COMMITTEE
WILL REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION.
AS WELL AS ALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS NOW NOT OPPOSED. AND I WANT
ALSO WANT TO REINFORCE IT UNDER
CURRENT LAW CANNABIS IS ALLOWED
IN THESE BUSES AND LIMO IS
RIGHT NOW THEY COULD GO IN. AND
SMOKE AS MUCH AS THEY WANT IN A
CAMP A LIMOUSINE OR A BUS. THIS
WILL CREATE OF. THE ROOF
REGULATIONS FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTION AND CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE RESPECT YESTERDAY VOTE
THANK YOU MA'AM. AND CHAIR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU I'M GOING TO.
PUT THAT ON CALL. YES IN AN.
WHAT WOULD WORK ON GETTING OUR
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS HERE LIKE
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR YOU.
VERY MUCH THANK YOU CALLING
THANK YOU MISTER HOW. MR WHITE
HOUSE SKI. YOU'LL BE PRESENTING
ON SB SIX SIX TEAM ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. OCEAN BY
MISS CARILLO IN A SECOND BY A
DOCTOR QUIRK YES THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THE COSTS
ARE MINOR AND OBSERVE ON THEIR
REGION I VOTE IF YOU HAVE. MISS
BARTOLO AS MY WITNESS THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU AS- I JUST WANT
TO BE CLEAR. THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN LAST WEEK IN THIS
COMMITTEE YES REDUCE THE AMOUNT
PROTECTED FROM SEIZURE FOR DEBT
COLLECTORS TO ONE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWENTY WITH
THIS AMOUNT IS THE MINIMUM
BASIC STANDARD FOR ADEQUATE
CARE THAT THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES TO DETERMINE FOR A
FAMILY OF FOUR. IN IRVINE
CALIFORNIA AREA THAT THEY NEED
TO SURVIVE AND I WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT I THINK OUR STAFF OF
HAD DISCUSSION ABOUT ENSURING
THAT THAT'S NOT STACKED ON TOP
OF THE ALLOWABLE EXPENSES IT IS
AN EITHER OR YES THAT THAT THAT
WAS OUR INTENTION AND IF WE
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED.
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE I'VE. YES
THAT'S RIGHT AS WELL YEAH I
WHEN I LOOK AT I THINK THE
EXISTING LAW. THANK YOU I'M
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT ON THE
FISCAL ANALYSIS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR JESSICA BARTLETT WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY OR SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
HE NOW SAYS PRETTY MUCH SAYS IT
ALL THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD
IS THAT. OUR LEGAL SERVICES
NETWORK THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SEE THESE CASES
EVERY DAY AS YOU KNOW WE ARE
INCREASINGLY OVERWHELMED WITH
THE CUTS. COMING DOWN THE PIKE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
PUBLIC CHARGE FOR SNAP CUTS FOR
HAD RULES THERE'S A TSUNAMI OF
WORK WE HAVE TO DO. WE ARE
EXHAUSTED TO THE EXTENT THAT
EVERY HOUR WE SPEND TRACKING
DOWN THESE ADDITIONAL THE THESE
THESE BANKS LEVIED OR EVICTIONS
HELPING PEOPLE LIVE ACTIONS
BECAUSE OF BANKS LEVIED. THAT'S
WORK WE CAN'T PUT TOWARDS THE
OTHER THE OTHER THINGS COMING
OUR WAY AND SO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA INVEST IN LEGAL
SERVICES AND YOU'VE GOT A
BETTER. INVESTMENT WHEN YOU
MAKE THE RULES WORK FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE THIS BILL WILL
HELP TO DO THAT AND WE ARE
TRAVEL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS. GOOD
MORNING DANIELLE KENDALL KAISER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION AND
ARE THIRTEEN. LEGAL AID SERVICE
PARTNERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TONY
GIPSON WITH ENCORE CAPITAL
GROUP HERE IN OPPOSITION I JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT WHILE
THERE WAS A SLIGHT REDUCTION
FROM 200-021-0007 HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR DOLLARS FOR THE
AMOUNT OF EXCEPTION THEY'RE
STILL ABSOLUTELY NO MEANS TEST
BEING ADDED AND THAT IS AN
AUTOMATIC EXEMPTION PROTECTING
ALL JUDGMENT DEBTORS FROM FROM
DEBTS THAT THEY MAY HAVE. THIS
IS VERY COSTLY TO THE STATE WE
BELIEVE THAT THE EX PARTE
REQUIREMENTS SAYS THAT WE SHALL
GO TO COURT HEARINGS TO
DETERMINE WHERE AND WHICH BANK
ACCOUNT THAT JUDGMENT DEBTORS
SHOULD APPLY THE EXEMPTION TO
WE BELIEVE THIS WILL CAUSE AN
INFLUX TO THE STATE WITH
THOUSANDS OF ADDITIONAL COURT
HEARINGS EVERY YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY THE INDEX THAT IS
BEING REFERENCED IN THE BILL
NOW THE M. B. S. A. C. INDEX IS
A NUMBER THAT CHANGES EVERY
YEAR AND SO FORMS AND
PROCEDURES BY JUDICIAL COUNCIL
WILL HAVE TO BE UPDATED VERY
REGULARLY. ALSO AN ADDITIONAL
COST TO THE STATE. AND FINALLY
THAT THE LOSS OF TAX REVENUE
FOR CREDITORS BUSINESSES AND
ANY SMALL BUSINESS THAT DOES
COLLECTIONS WORK. OR HAS DEBTS.
THIS COULD BE YOUR LOCAL
PLUMBER. IT WILL BE COSTLY
BECAUSE THIS ESSENTIALLY ALLOWS
JUDGMENT DEBTORS TO ABATE SEVEN
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR. IN DEBTS
FOR ALL JUDGMENT DEBTORS NO
QUESTIONS ASKED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. TIM LYNCH
ON BEHALF OF THE RECEIVABLES
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION WE STILL
HAVE SIGNIFICANT POLICY
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL BUT- I
SURE THE CONCERNS I REGARDING
THE FISCAL IMPACTS ON THE
COURTS BECAUSE THE HEARING IS
MANDATORY. ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION CHRISTINA GALLAGHER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLECTORS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX ONE SIX
UNFORTUNATELY THE AMENDMENTS
DON'T FIX OUR CONCERNS THANK
YOU THANK YOU DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. WE DO NOT HAVE A FILE
AT THIS TIME. SEE NO QUESTIONS
CENTER WHAT CASKEY AYE. YOU
KNOW AND I KNOW THE OPPOSITION
IS UP WELL I HEARD THIS BILL
MANY TIMES I'M TRYING TO WRAP
MY- ARMS AROUND. TRYING TO GET
AT WHAT I THINK THE ADVOCATES
ARE TRYING TO DO IS. IS
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE HILL ARE
NOT GOING TO HAVE AN ATTORNEY
CANNOT WELL REPRESENT
THEMSELVES IN COURT I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS FIX OBVIOUSLY IT'S
NOT A PERFECT FIX BUT I WANT TO
THINK THE SENATOR FOR. AT LEAST
WORKING WITH ME MY STAFF TRYING
TO GET A PLACE WHERE I'M MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE BILL AN
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS SAID THAT
RIGHT NOW IF WE NEED TO TAKE ON
THE FLOOR I STILL THINK YOU
HAVE. A. A TOUGH ROAD AHEAD BUT
ON THE FISCAL WE AT. THINK IT
SHOULD GET OUT TODAY SO. GOOD
LUCK I'VE I LIVE ON THAT ROAD.
HOWEVER I LIVE ON THAT ROAD
AHEAD IF WITH REGARD TO THE
IMPACT THAT THIS IS FLOOD OF EX
PARTE APPLICATIONS YOU KNOW THE
SHELL WAS NEGOTIATED WITH THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ALL THE
BANKS ARE OFF THE BILL THEIR
THEIR OPPOSITION SO THAT WAS A
NEGOTIATED LANGUAGE THE SECOND
IS THAT. REMEMBER THE DEBTORS
NOW THEY HAVE AN ABILITY TO GO
IN AND DO A CLAIM EXEMPTION
WITH A NO LOOK SEVENTEEN
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR YOU COULD
SEE THAT COME CRASHING DOWN
BECAUSE PEOPLE GONNA HAVE SOME
MONEY TO EXIST THE EX PARTY IS
GOING TO BE THE INSTITUTIONS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO GO THERE
AND THAT'S- UP TO THEM IF THEY
FEEL THAT THEY NEED. TO GET
MORE MONEY AFTER THE NO LOOKS
AT WHERE THEY GET THE MONEY
AFTER SEVENTEEN TWENTY FOUR SO
WE DON'T THINK THIS IS GOING TO
BE THAT GREAT IMPACT ON THE
COURTS AFTER HE FELL OFF THE
CHANGE. OKAY I'M WITHOUT I'LL
TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES LIKE
IT'S HOW. TO BE ROLL CALL WITH
MISTER CALDERON NOT VOTING
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MISTER
WEINER. MISTER WIENER. IT'S
GOING TO BE PRESENTING N SB
ONE TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE A BILL I
LOVE PLEASE DON'T TALK YOURSELF
OUT OF IT I WILL START BY
SAYING I AGREE THAT CALTRANS
HAS EMBARRASSED THEMSELVES WITH
THE PROJECTION THAT THEY HAVE
GIVEN US AND YOU MAY PROCEED
FROM THERE PLEASE QUICKLY OKAY.
HE SAID IT WAS SUCH A JOY
MOUNTAINS THANK YOU. COLOR
THANK YOU AND I'M SURE I'LL BE
VERY BRIEF SINCE YOU SINCE YOU
TOOK A BIG PIECE OF WHAT I WAS
GOING TO SAY. THE COST ESTIMATE
THE CALTRANS PROVIDED IS AN
ABSOLUTE EMBARRASSMENT TO THE
AGENCY AND THE AGENCY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF ITSELF. FOR DOING
THIS. THIS BILL IS SIMPLY ABOUT
ASKING CALTRANS THAT WHEN YOU
HAVE STATE HIGHWAYS THAT ARE
CITY SURFACE STREETS THAT
PEOPLE ARE WALKING ON AND
BIKING ON. THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ENSURING THAT THOSE STREETS ARE
SAFE. FOR CHILDREN OR SENIORS
TO CROSS THE STREET. TO RIDE A
BIKE THEY SAY THEY WANT TO DO
THIS BUT THEY'RE NOT DOING A
AND THE BILL SIMPLY TELLS ON
THE WHEN THEY'RE ALREADY DOING.
A PROJECT THAT THEY HAVE TO
CONSIDER DO WE STRIPED BY
PLANES DO WE ACTUALLY PUT CROSS
WALKS INTO THE PEOPLE CAN SAVE
ACROSS THE STREET. WE'RE NOT
EVEN ASKING THEM TO INITIATE
NEW PROJECTS WITHIN WHEN YOU'RE
ALREADY DOING A PROJECT YOU
HAVE TO WORK WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY. TO DO THIS CALDERON
SO THEY'LL COME IN HERE AND
SAID THAT IT WILL COST THEM
FOUR POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
PER MILE. TO DO THAT THAT'S HOW
THEY COME UP WITH THEIR
RIDICULOUS ONE BILLION DOLLAR
PRICE TAG ON THE BILL WHEN WE
KNOW THAT IS PROJECTS COSTING
WE'VE CANVASSED AGENCIES AROUND
THE STATE. ANYWHERE FROM TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER MILE TO AT
THE HIGH END SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND IF THEY COME IN WITH A
FOUR POINT FIVE. MILLION
DOLLARS THIS IS A FARCICAL COST
ESTIMATE AND I TRULY HOPE THAT
THE COMMITTEE REJECTS THAT I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
I KNOW THIS IS GOING TO SPENT
THAT I APPRECIATE THE TIME
THANK YOU. DO DO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR THAT. WE'RE GOING
TO THINK THAT ALL RIGHT. JUST
NAME ORGANIZATION. SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL. I CAROLING ON THAT
MARYLAND AND RATE IN THE CITY
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION PROUD BECAUSE
SPONSORING SUPPORT. SYLVIA'S
THE LEASH ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO MUNICIPAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. A
STEVE WELCOME HAVE THE L.
MEDICARE TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION SUPPORT. ROSS
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF THE C.
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. DAVID AS
IT ON BEHALF OF A RP CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. SPEAKER IS IN
OPPOSITION SEE NINE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. FIND IT'S SUPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE I FIGURED. ALL
RIGHT NO SO QUESTIONS WHICH ARE
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
SUPPORT IF THIS COMES OFF
SUSPENSE THANK YOU WE'LL DEAL
WITH IT ON SPEND STYLE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MISS COLORADO.
WHO. HOME IS KIND OF A AT.
DOESN'T SOUND GOOD. CERTAIN
TOXIC CHEMICALS IN OUR BE
WASTING TANKS WE'VE WORKED
REALLY HARD AT TRYING TO JUST
OF. TO RATIONALIZE WHY THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD ESTIMATED
WOULD COST THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS JUST TO PUT UP
SIGNAGE AND WE'VE WORKED WITH
THE THAT WATER BOARD AND WHEN
SENATOR MINING WAS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HE RAN THIS BILL AND IT
THE COST WAS FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS SO WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
NUMBER IS OVER INFLATED. THAT
IT'S PROBABLY A LOT CLOSER TO
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND WITH
THAT WOULD WOULD SUBMIT TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY SUPPORTERS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR J. SELECTED WITH ADULTS
DEAN GILBERT ROBESON SMITH ON
BEHALF OF CAN'T COUNT NOW. FOR
THE ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATELY
OWNED CAMPGROUNDS AND RV PARKS
IN THE STATE ONE THING ALL ADD
TO WHAT THE SENATOR HAS SAID IS
THAT AS SHE SHE'S POINTED OUT.
WE ARE WORKING ACTIVELY ON
MEMBERS WITH THE WATER BOARD TO
MAKE SURE THIS BILL IS
IDENTICAL FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL. TO THE BILL
THAT WAS FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
NINE YEARS AGO. THERE IS AN
EXISTING PROGRAM TO BAN
PRODUCTS THAT ARE JUST LIKE THE
ONES WE ARE WORKING ON IN THIS
BILL. IT'S HARD FOR US TO
IMAGINE WHY IT WOULD COST OVER
A MILLION DOLLARS TO INTEGRATE
THESE TOXIC CHEMICALS INTO THAT
EXISTING PROGRAM. A
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
THOSE IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. FINANCES OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
WORKLOAD FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
WITHOUT PROVIDING FUNDING TO
SUPPORT THE COSTS. DETAILS HE
IS CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED TO
AFTER COMPLYING WITH A
SPECIFIED REGULATORY PROCESS
BEYOND THE CHEMICALS LISTED IN
THIS BILL. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL STATES ENFORCEMENT IS
CONTINGENT UPON FUTURE
APPROPRIATIONS BY THE
LEGISLATURE. HOWEVER THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL ACCOUNT
REQUIRES A SIGNIFICANT FEE
INCREASE FOR THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL TO BE ENFORCEABLE.
ABSENCE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE
THIS BILL RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND PRESSURE TO BACK FILL THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE CONTROL COUNT.
ALL RIGHT. ANY QUESTIONS SEE
NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO MEET
YOUR SECOND BILL I YES I WOULD
MADAM CHAIR IT'S ALSO SUSPENDS
CANDIDATE AND I THINK IT'S AS
BEFORE FOURTEEN FOUR ONE FOUR
YES. YES MADAM CHAIR. I JUST
WANTED TO INFORM THE COMMITTEE
THAT WE ARE TAKING SOME
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS IF THIS
GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE. THAT
WOULD. BASICALLY AT THAT THE
WATER BOARD IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
THAT CAN CAN COMMUNITY HAVE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR. THE
STREAMLINED ONLINE THE BILL
WITH EXISTING PROCESSES WHICH
WILL BRING REAP RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS COST THIS
BILL GOES HAND IN HAND WITH SB
TWO HUNDRED WHICH IS TO START.
CONSOLIDATING NONCONTIGUOUS
CONTAMINATED WELLS IN THAT
BETTER LOCATED UP AND DOWN THAT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND WITH
THAT I WOULD THAT THE ALIGNMENT
REDUCES. THE COST BY TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND THAT'S
THE REASON I WANTED. THANK YOU
I'M SUPPORTERS. DANIEL GLASSER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION AS CENTER
COVER YEAR NOTED WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING IN CLOSE COLLABORATION
WITH THE WATER BOARD. IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMUNITY
ON STREAMLINING AMENDMENTS THAT
WILL DRAMATICALLY REDUCE COSTS
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU. JAMIE
MINOR THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
ON BEHALF OF THE EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT ALSO
IN SUPPORT. APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS AND THINK THAT
THEY'RE ESSENTIAL ESPECIALLY AS
SB TWO HUNDRED FUND START TO
COME UP TO GET A GET OUT THE
DOOR. THIS IS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE SPENT IN AN EFFICIENT AND
SUSTAINABLE WAY TO ENSURE THAT
THESE SYSTEMS ARE SUSTAINABLE
AND FUTURE THANKS. THANK YOU
DIGITAL SUPPORTERS. THAT'S ALL
ALSO ON BEHALF OF INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN THE
SANTA ANA WATERSHEDS PROJECT A
THIRTY IN STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING ROSIE THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING CAM MERRY
I KNOW IT'S SANTA CLARA VALLEY
WATER DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING PAUL THEMSELVES
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
AND THE CITY OF ROSEVILLE AND
SUPPORT. ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE DO NOT HAVE A FILE
AT THIS TIME GREAT THANK YOU
THINK THEY PRESS CORREA THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT MISTER WEST SO.
SENATOR YOU ARE GOING TO
PRESENT ON SB SIX NINETY EIGHT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE'VE MADE MOTION BY MISCREANT
A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SIMPLY SB SIX
NINETY WOULD PROVIDE MUCH
LEADER REAL RELIEF ITSELF BAKED
BEANS MY DISTRICT SUFFERING
FROM WATER CONTAMINATION DUE TO
RUN OFF TO SO SIT WITH THE
TIJUANA RIVER VALLEYS MANY OF
YOU KNOW. WE WERE ABLE TO THE
CHIEF FIFTEEN MILLION IN THE
BUDGET FOR THIS TO THE SEND
THIS BILL TAKES ADVANTAGE OF
FEDERAL LAW IT WHICH IS UNDER
THE WATER CLEAN THE CLEAN WATER
ACT FEDERAL CLEAN WATER ACT
THAT AUTHORIZES STATES TO
COMPEL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO CLEAN. UP THE WATER BODIES
ARE NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
WITH THE CLEAN WATER ACT. THIS
WOULD. REQUIRED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO BUILD A WASTE
CAPTURE RUNOFF INTERCEPTION.
AND DIVERSION STRUCTURE ALONG
THAT THE QUAN REVELLI TO FOR A
FIX THIS PROBLEM AND COURSE
WITH THE FUNDING THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING WITHOUT PROVIDE SOME
ASSISTANCE. TO THE TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOING THAT.
AS AS MANY OF YOU KNOW WE
ALLOCATED SOME MONEY. HERE AT
THIS LEGISLATURE TO CREATE THE
STUDY THAT WILL NOT ONLY. MAKE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS NEEDED TO
FIX THIS THIS PROBLEM BUT ALSO
REQUIRE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO MAKE THESE IMPROVEMENTS ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO HERE IN SUPPORT ON
THE FISCAL MATTERS AS CENTER
HUESO MENTIONED FIFTEEN MILLION
WAS SET ASIDE IN THE BUDGET FOR
STORING THESE TYPES OF
PROJECTS. BEING ABLE TO DO
THESE PROJECTS NOW AND NOT
ADDRESSING THOSE POLLUTION
IMPACTS CURRENTLY WILL HELP
OFFSET ANY FUTURE. GREATER COST
BOTH TO THE STATE THE LOCALS
AND PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
THOSE IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY INDICATES THIS BILL
HAS NO FISCAL IMPACT HOWEVER
FINANCE OPPOSES THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WILL REQUIRE THE
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS BASED ON
STUDIES CONDUCTED PURSUANT TO
CHAPTER FIVE FORTY TWO STATUES
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH MAY
OR MAY NOT BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE ALLOWABLE USES OF THOSE
FUNDS ON EXPORTS LISTING
APPROPRIATIONS. I SEE NO
QUESTIONS OR THANK YOU FOR
INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE I
WANNA MAKE SURE I AM ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR I'M NOT ALREADY. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL. MR
UMBERG. MISTER MERCURY FREEZING
ON SB FOUR FIFTY ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. IT'S MADE
BY DOCTOR QUIRK AT SECOND BY A
MISS KOREA. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THE PURPOSE OF SB
FOUR FIFTY IS TO ALLOW THE
CONVERSION OF MOTELS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY BEING USED BY TRAINS
ITS INTO A MORE PERMANENT FORM
OF HOUSING SIMPLY TO INSTALL A
KITCHENETTE WAS KITCHENETTE IS
INSTALLED THAT IT CAN BE USED
AS A PLACE WHERE FOLKS CAN SEEK
EMPLOYMENT OR AT LEAST A
PERMANENT ADDRESS FROM WHICH
THEY CAN SIX POINT THE WHAT IT
DOES IS IT EXEMPTS. THEM FROM
THE THREAT OF SEQUEL LAWSUITS
WITH ME HERE AS A MISSING THE
BROWN ON BEHALF OF LONG BEACH
AND JOHN KENNEDY WE HAVE THE
ROLE COMES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANY BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF. LONG BEACH WHERE THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL ASK FOR
AND I BILL. AND JOHN KENNEDY
WITH RC RC WERE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL IT WILL USE
OVERALL PROJECT COST AND REDUCE
DELAYS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS AND
LEGAL DELAYS. SO THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS. WE ONLY
HAVE A THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT ALSO TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES A
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. RUSS
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO
MERITORIOUS AND BERGEN SUPPORT.
SO HIS SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN
SUPPORT. NICOLE ORNAMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT. STATE CAROLING OTHER
STANISLAUS COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
AT ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
CENA UNDERWENT A FINANCE
FINANCES I HAVE A POSITION ON
THE SPOT THIS TIME THIS BILL
HAS NO FISCAL IMPACT TO THE
STATE FINANCE NOTES THAT TO THE
EXTENT THIS INCREASES HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS THAT QUALIFY FOR
SEQUEL EXEMPTION THIS BILL MAY
RESULT IN COST SAVINGS TO
OWNERS OF SPECIFIC STRUCTURES
AS WELL AS DEVELOPERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WILL NOT HAVE TO
UNDERTAKE ENVIRONMENTALLY FEES.
THANK YOU. TAKE THAT IS CLOSE
YES. RELIABLE THANK YOU THAT
GETS ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU.
SENATOR MITCHELL. YOU'LL BE
PRESENT SB SIX THIRTY NINE AND
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WE ARE MOTION BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE IN A SECOND BY A
DOCTOR QUIRK. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR TOP OF THE
MORNING COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL
SIX THREE NINE WILL INCREASE IN
STRENGTH IN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES MEDICAL PROVIDERS TO
GET PATIENTS BASIC INFORMATION
MANY CONSUMERS DO NOT
UNDERSTAND THE RAMIFICATIONS.
OF PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN
DEFERRED INTEREST PROVISIONS I
MADE THESE PRODUCTS ARE MARKET
WITH AN INTRODUCTORY PERIOD OF
0% INTEREST. AT THE SUGGESTION
OF THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CHAIR WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL. TO RESOLVE A SPECIFIC
CONCERN FOR OVER A MONTH BUT WE
WERE UNABLE TO FIND A
RESOLUTION. OF THE POLICY
COMMITTEE CHAIRS ARE AWARE OF
THE ROUTE WE'VE TAKEN WITH THE
BILL AND THEY ARE IN SUPPORT
THIS BILL HAS MINIMAL AND
OBSERVABLE COSTS I ASKED FOR IT
EITHER. THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. MORNING CHEN FLOOR IN
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND I WOULD JUST
ADD GIVEN THE MINIMAL CASA THIS
HAS TO THE STATE AND THE HUGE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT WILL
IT IT WILL ENACTED WILL HELP
LOW INCOMES LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS IN PARTICULAR NOT RUN
AT MEDICAL DEBT. WONDERFUL
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS. THE HOLE
IN THE CALIFORNIA SENATE THE
GUILT AT WORK IN SUPPORT.
RONALD COLMAN ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOURS IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ESTIMATES MINOR TROUBLE COSTS
DC ALSO NOTES THE HIT KILLING
ARTS PROGRAMS NOT FIRST PAYMENT
ISSUES AND ANY ADDITIONAL COSTS
WITHIN HER IF AND WHEN A
CONSUMER FILED A COMPLAINT
AGAINST A LICENSEE WITH ONE OF
THE HEALING ARTS PROGRAMS ANY
INCREASES IN MONITORING AND
RESOLVING COMPLAINTS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE MINOR AFFORDABLE
AS WELL. THE BILL STATES THAT
ANY PATIENT SEEKING DAMAGES AS
A RESULT OF THE LICENSING VITAL
LICENSEE VIOLATING THE BILL
WOULD NEED TO FILE CIVIL SUIT
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS BILL US
TO TELL COURTS CASELOAD COURT
BATTLE COURT BACKLOG MAY
INCREASE AND COULD CREATE
PRESSURE ON THE GENERAL FUND TO
HANDLE INCREASED FLOWED HOWEVER
WE NOTE THAT THE COURTS ARE NOT
TYPICALLY RECEIVE FUNDING ON A
WORKLOAD BASIS THERE WAS THIS
PARTICULAR CASE WILL BECOME
SIGNIFICANT AND CAN BE
DOCUMENTED IT IS LIKELY TO BE
ABSORBED. THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT AND TO KEEP
THE OFFICE GOING. ALL RIGHT
WHAT SHE SAID OKAY THIS BILL
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING BUT MISTER MISTER
OBERNOLTE VERY NICE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU. AS SEEN NO AUTHORS AT THIS
TIME WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
SENATORS WHO HAVE BILLS THAT
MISTER ALLEN MISS SKINNER
MISTER MCGUIRE. MISS SKINNER.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON SB
THREE TEN AS YOU MAKE YOUR WAY
UP IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY MISS CARILLO AND SECONDED BY
A DOCTOR QUIRK THANK YOU SO
MUCH SIR MEMBERS JUST VERY
BRIEFLY I WE WILL BE AMENDING
THIS BILL ON THE FLOOR. AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WILL BE
TAKING WILL HAVE THE D. A.'S
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL SO THEY
WILL REMOVE THEIR OPPOSITION WE
JUST FINISHED THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND THE HEAD OF
THE DA SAYS THE REPRESENTATIVE
FOR THE DA SENSATIONAL MEETING
MEETING WITH MY STAFF TOMORROW.
TOO AND THERE WAS AMENDMENTS
WON'T AFFECT MAKE THE RIGHT TO
SERVE ON A JURY PARALLEL TO OUR
CURRENT RIGHT TO VOTE BUT IT
WILL ADDITIONALLY EXCLUDE
FELONY XXL FENDERS SO PRIMARILY
IT JUST PUTS THE BILL IN THE
SAME IN THE SAME WAY THAT WE
NOW IN CALIFORNIA. GIVE A
FORMER ON THE RIGHT TO VOTE WE
WOULD BE PARALLEL IN TERMS OF
THEIR ABILITY TO SERVE ON A
JURY ONCE WE MAKE THE
AMENDMENTS. WITHOUT A WITH MY-
WITNESSES THANK YOU ON THE
FISCAL. MAYBE. I YEAH GO AHEAD
I'M SORRY SORRY. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS BRANDON WOODS IN THE
PUBLIC FUNDED I'M TO COUNTY AND
PASS PRESIDENCY PDA LIKE
MICHAEL PRESENTED HERE I THINK
I'M UNIQUELY QUALIFIED TO
DISCUSS THIS BILL I'VE BEEN A
PUBLIC DEFENDER FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS NOW. I AM THE FIRST
BLACK CHIEF PUBLIC FOR THE
AMERICAN HISTORY AND CURRENTLY
I AM THE ONLY BLACK CHIEF
PUBLIC DEFENDER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I SPENT MY ENTIRE
CAREER KATIE FOR PEOPLE ACCUSED
OF CRIMES. I'VE SPENT MY ENTIRE
CAREER TRYING TO GET THEIR
LIVES BACK WHEN THEY'VE BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME. SO I
CANNOT TELL YOU HOW OFTEN I'VE
SAT AT A TABLE LIKE THIS WHERE
MY CLIENT WHO IS BLACK OR BROWN
HAS BEEN. CHARGED WITH A CRIME
GOING TO JURY TRIAL AND THEY'D
HAVE A JURY. WHO LOOKS NOTHING
LIKE THEM. THIS RULE HARKENS
BACK TO A TIME WHERE JURIES
WERE COMPOSED OF ALL WHITE MEN.
SO WE HAVE SEEN THE
CONSEQUENCES IN THIS RULE THIS
LAW.WE'VE ALL READ ABOUT CASE
OF WRONGFUL CONVICTIONS THAT
STEM FROM RACIAL BIAS IN
POLICING PROSECUTION AND WE
SEEN JURIES THAT ARE NOT
DIVERSE CONTINUE TO UPHOLD
THESE CONVICTIONS THAT A
WRONGFUL. AS WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
BLACK PEOPLE SEVEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY BE ROUGHLY CONVICTED OF
MURDER AND WHAT PEOPLE. SB
THREE TEN AS OF LAW THAT CAN
FIX THAT. CURRENTLY OVER 30% OF
BLACK MEN ARE. KEPT FROM
SERVING AS YOURS NO ONE WOULD
PUT A LAW IN PLACE LIKE THAT
RIGHT NOW. SO. IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR US TO REMEMBER AS A CENTER
SAID THIS BILL WILL NOT MAKE IT
AUTOMATIC THAT FELONS WILL BE
ABLE TO SIT AS JURORS THOUGH
STILL ADORE POSSUM PLACE CLUB
OR THE OR THE JURY SELECTION
ANYONE WHO HAS A BIAS WILL BE
ABLE TO BE EXCLUDED BY THE
JUDGE. OR BY A PROSECUTOR DE A
DEFENSE ATTORNEY I KNOW THAT
THERE IS A LOT OF FEAR. AROUND
THIS. THE PLACE THAT FEAR COMES
FROM OPPOSITION. OUR PEOPLE ARE
SCARED OF PEOPLE HAVE FELONY
CONVICTIONS THEY'RE SCARED OF
PEOPLE WHO. OUR OTHERS AND THAT
FEAR REALLY IS WHAT IS TEARING
THE COUNTRY APART RIGHT NOW. SO
I AM HONORED TO BE HERE IN
FRONT OF YOU ADVOCATING FOR
SIMPLE CHANGE IN THE LAW THAT
IS VERY VERY MINOR FISCAL
IMPACT. THIS LAW WILL BE ABLE
TO BRING BACK COMMUNITY
HUMANITY TO MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
SO AS I CONCLUDE I JUST WANNA
TELL YOU BRIEFLY I'M YOUR TIME
IS UP I'M SORRY AND I DO WANT
TO REMIND PEOPLE WE NEED TO
KEEP IT TO A FISCAL I ALSO THIS
IS. REALLY UNUSUAL AND SO I'M
SORRY SEVEN NOT DISCUSS THIS
WITH YOU SKINNER. THE
AMENDMENTS YOU OUTLINE FOR
TAKING TO THE FLOOR WILL
REQUIRE THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO PULL THIS BILL
BACK HERE. BECAUSE LOOKING
INTO. WHETHER SOMEBODY HAS A
SEX OFFENSE WILL ADD. POSSIBLY
A COST WHAT I'M GOING TO ASK
YOU TO DO IF IT'S ALL RIGHT
SOME ASK THE MOTION AND THE
SECOND TO WITHDRAW THEIR
MOTION. PUT IT OVER FOR A WEEK
MAKE THE AMENDMENTS HERE AND
HERE IT NEXT WEEK. DOES THAT
WORK FOR YOU. YES THAT WOULD
WORK. OKAY WITH THAT IT IS A
MAKERS. ALL RIGHT SO MUCH
CAREER WITH YOU HER MOTION THAT
MEANS WHAT SINCE EVERYBODY'S
HERE LET'S GO AHEAD AND FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY HERE THROUGH THE
SUPPORTERS PLEASE ONLY TO THE
FISCAL WHICH IS KIND OF
IRRELEVANT RIGHT NOW BUT IF YOU
WANT TO JUST REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT EIGHT I'M SORRY IT'S
JUST THE AMENDMENTS WROTE
TRIGGER PULLING BACK AND I
DON'T WANT TO MAKE MISTER
CALDERON DO THAT ON THE FLOOR
NEXT WEEK SO. LET'S JUST CLEAN
IT UP HERE WHICH I THINK WILL
HELP ME YEAH. THANK YOU OKAY.
ALL RIGHT I AM. JAMES BUT ALL
I'M A PROFESSOR AT CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY LONG BEACH. I'M ALSO
PRACTICING ATTORNEY INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M A CONVICTED
FELON. SO WHAT AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE WITH THE SET UP IS THIS
IDEA THAT I COULD TRY CASE IN
ANY COURT HOUSE THE STATE BUT
YET I COULDN'T SIT ON A JURY IN
ANY COURT HOUSE THE STATE EVEN
MY IN A MINOR CIVIL DISPUTE. TO
THE FISCAL POINT I'VE DONE
YEARS OF RESEARCH ON SALINGER
EXCLUSION YOU CAN GOOGLE IT
TONIGHT AND EVERY ARTICLE YOU
FINAL BE ONE WRITTEN BY ME. I
DID A LOT OF WORK IN MAINE THE
ONLY STATE THAT PER SE HAS NO
DISQUALIFICATION FOR THOSE WHO
ARE CONVICTED OF FELONIES. AND
I CAN TELL YOU AS FAR AS FISKE.
IT'S NOTHING. THE TOURNEY'S RUN
THE RAP SHEETS AND OVER THE-
TEN OVER THE PUBLIC DEFENDER.
AND THEN THEY PROCEED WITH WHAT
DEAR AS ANY OTHER STATE WHAT.
AS FAR AS- FISCAL I THINK WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT WHICH IS THE THREAT
CONVICTED FELONS POSED TO THE
JURY PROCESS FIRST THE BENEFITS
YOU MAY REACH. BY HAVING FOLKS
A FELONY CONVICTIONS TAKE PART
IN THIS PROCESS. WE KNOW THAT
THIS PROCESS CAN BE
TRANSFORMATIVE IN TERMS OF RE
ENTRY. TO THE SELF ESTEEM
TURNED A CRIMINAL THIS
INSTANCE. FRANKLY IT MAKES THAT
PROCESS A LOT SMOOTHER RIGHT.
WHEN YOU ARE REMINDED
PERPETUALLY THAT YOU ARE
DIFFERENT WHEN YOU ARE REMINDED
PERPETUALLY THAT YOU. CAN'T DO
WHAT EVERYONE ELSE CAN DO. IT
MAKES REINTEGRATION RE ENTRY
THAT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT. SO
WHILE THERE MAY NOT BE OBVIOUS
FISCAL ADVANTAGES TO THIS ON
THE FRONT END. THERE CERTAINLY
ARE IN THE BACK AND BY HAVING
HEALTHIER MORE PRODUCTIVE
PARTICIPATING CITIZENS. LOOK
I'VE DONE RESEARCH ON THIS FOR
LIKE I SAID TEN YEARS. I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THERE IS MINIMAL
TO NO THREAT AND THAT. MINIMAL
TO NO THREAT INCLUDES FOLKS.
JUST FOR THE RECORD ON
SUPERVISION OR FOLKS WITH SEX
OFFENSES. THE WAY MAIN DOES IT
IS THE WAY I BELIEVE CALIFORNIA.
ON A DO IT I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT'S NOT WHERE WE'RE GOING.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE ALL RIGHT.
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION
BENCHER MEMBERS AS ARE THE
OTHER HALF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MAKE AYE JENKINS WITH
CASE STREET CONSULTING AND
STRONG SUPPORTER ON BEHALF OF
WORK EQUITY. I'M SURE MEMBERS
KEVIN BACON AMERICAN CIVIL
LIBERTIES UNION CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON THE OTHER NUMBER PER
SE NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. KATY DICKSON ON WE
HAVE ALL OF US AND NONE IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING THERE ARE
SUPER IN POLICY MANAGEFLITTER
SERVICE PRISON WITH CHILDREN IN
STRONG SUPPORT. TALK ABOUT BARN
BEHALF OF LEGAL SERVICES PRISON
WHICH WAS ALL OF US IN ON AN
EAST OPEN USED CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WONDER DOLLY
PARTS FOR ALL OF US AND NINE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IS THERE
OPPOSITION. SEE NINE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION AT THIS TIME THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL INDICATES
ACOSTA SOCIALLY WITH THIS BILL
WILL BE MINOR IMPOSSIBLE
ABSORBABLE IF THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD THE STATE ENTITY
RESPONSIBLE FOR RECORDS OF
STATE TAX FILERS PROVIDES A
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WITH THE
NECESSARY INFORMATION TO SOME
INJURES AT THE TIME OF THIS
ANALYSIS THE FTV HAD NOT
PROVIDED AN ANALYSIS ON THE
FISCAL IMPACT OF THE BILL AS OF
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS. A
PART OF TO BE ANALYSIS RAISE
CONCERNS THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT PROVIDE THE SPECIFICITY
REQUIRED FOR THE A TO BE
DETERMINED HOW THEY WOULD
COMPLY WITH THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL THEREFORE THIS BILL
COULD RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS FOR THE FTV WE KNOW THAT
IF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS
UNABLE TO CONSOLIDATE JURY
MASTERLESS USING STE TAXI TAX
FILER INFORMATION PROVIDED BY
OF TV IT COULD LEAD TO
INCREASED LITIGATION AGAINST
TRIAL COURTS FOR FAILURE TO
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE JURY POOL
GIVEN THE COURTS WOULD BE OUT
OF COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATURE
BY NOT UTILIZING ALL THE JURY
MASTERLESS. ALL RIGHT. SKINNER
WE THE BILL HAS BEEN HURT FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY WE WILL RESET IT
NEXT WEEK AND GERMAN YOU CAN
COME BACK BUT BY ALL MEANS YOU
DON'T NEED TO ADD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU ARE
ALSO STILL IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE F. T. BE SO IF WE HAVE ANY
RESOLUTION THERE WE WILL ALSO
TALK TO YOUR STAFF IN THIS
INTERIM WEEK AROUND THAT. THANK
YOU AND I NOW THAT. TIME IS OF
THE ESSENCE OF THIS I KNOW YOU
KNOW THAT. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION I'M SORRY FOR
THAT KIND OF A RELEASE ALL.
ACTION AND WE WILL REHEAR IT AS
AMENDED NEXT WEEK GREAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AM I WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS IN THE AUDIENCE IN
IT'S HARD WHEN WE HAVE
COMPELLING STORIES TO TELL THAT
THIS IS NOT A POLICY COMMITTEE.
AND SO IF WE CAN KEEP COMMENTS
TO. FISCAL MATTERS IT REALLY
HELPS BEAT US ALONG THE POLICY
ON THESE MATTERS WERE HEARD IN
POLICY COMMITTEE OR THE BILL
WOULD NOT BE HERE. WITH THAT.
MISS WICKS. ACR NINETY EIGHT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE'LL KEEP IT SHORT MUCH MY
MUSKRAT A SECOND BY MISTER
CALDERON. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT OR JUST THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE INSURANCE AND HEALTH
CARE SERVICES IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO USE THE FULL POWERS
OF THEIR OFFICES TO ENSURE THAT
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS AND
HEALTH INSURERS COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS ON
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY AND
ADDICTION EQUITY. THIS
RESOLUTION HAS NO STATE COSTS.
I WILL IT MIGHT. WITNESS SELF
INTRODUCED I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY BOOK. THING CAM GOOD
MORNING ADRIN SHELTON US TIMER
INSTITUTE WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF THIS RESOLUTION WE BELIEVE
THIS RESOLUTION IS SO IMPORTANT
BECAUSE ACHIEVING TRUE. AT
PARITY FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE WILL SAVE THE
STATE. SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
COSTS MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
ARE THE LEADING CAUSE OF
DISABILITY NATIONWIDE IT'S
COSTING US BILLIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR CONNIE DELGADO A BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BORN THINK
YOU'RE THE CARRY FORM IN
SUPPORT. RYAN BEESON WITH THE
NATIONAL UNION OF HEALTH CARE
WORKERS PROD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT. DANNY OFFER
WITH PLATINUM VISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWN AS NON CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION SEE NINE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NO FILE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU THIS GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANKS THANK YOU.
MISTER GIBSON. I'M SORRY MISTER
GIBSON I DID SEE MR ALLEN
SITTING THERE. HE BEAT YOU TO
IT I AM SO SORRY. WE TRY TO BE
FAIR MISTER ALLEN SB SEVEN
FORTY TWO ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THE MOTION BY MS
CREE ON A SECOND MY DOCTOR
QUIRK. I THINK YOU MEMBERS ON
THIS THIS. ADDRESSES AN ISSUE
THAT IS THIS KIND OF BEEN ON MY
MIND FOR A LITTLE WHILE WHICH
IS THAT WE DON'T CURRENTLY
ALLOW PEOPLE TO GET ON IT
ALREADY OPERATING AMTRAK BUS
BETWEEN TWO LOCATIONS AND IN
LESS THE PASSENGER IS GOING TO
BE WRITING A RAIL EITHER AT
THE- FRONT UNDER THE BACK AND.
OLD RULED NEEDS CHANGING WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DROP ALL GET ALL
THE OPPOSITION TO DROP. THE
COMMITTEES NOW SAYS NOTES COSTA
CALTRANS ARE MINOR AND ABSORB
ALL THERE'S POTENTIAL FOR. NEW
STATE REVENUE ACTUALLY
RESULTING FROM CROSSING
AGREEMENTS AND I RESPECT
RESTAURANT ABOUT. AT. SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF PULLED US IN WITH
THE RAIL PASSENGER ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA A PROUD CO
SPONSOR THIS PUTS PASSENGERS
INTO EMPTY BUS SEATS AND
IMPROVED MOBILITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE WE STRONGLY US FOR
SUPPORT THANK YOU I LOVE IT
SEVENTEEN JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY AND THE SUCH A VIRAL
WORKING GROUP SPONSORING THIS.
IN STRONG SUPPORT. ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS OF ROSS BUCKLEY WITH
A FEW SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
STEVE ALL COMING UP THIS NUMBER
AND EVERY REAL TRANSIT DISTRICT
AND THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR RECORDED TRANSPORTATION
SUPPORT. JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CAPITOL CORRIDOR JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
CAROLINE UNDER THE SAN JOAQUIN
STANISLAUS COUNTY PARTS OF
SUPERVISORS AT THIS POINT.
HERE'S AN OPPOSITION. SEEN AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FINANCES
NEUTRAL BUT NOTES CONCERNS AT
THE BILL PUTS GPAS WITH
EXPERTISE IN PROVIDING
INTERCITY PASSENGER RAIL AND
BUS SERVICE THAT CONNECT
PASSENGERS TO RAIL STATIONS IN
THE BUSINESS OF NON REAL
RELATED BY SERVICES. THANK YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. IT'S
JUST ASK FOR NINE AS FOR EVER
THANK YOU LIKE IT'S OUT ON ANY
RIGHT. I KNOW QUE THANK YOU. MR
GIVE SAID IT'S YOUR TURN NOW.
ACR ARE TWENTY EIGHT ENJOY THE
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION MOVED BY
MISTER OBERNOLTE SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN IDLE THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT. SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE
SEE NO QUESTIONS ARE GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL THINK AS YOU GET
SEN. ALL RIGHT. AS WE STILL
NEED SOME FOLKS TO SHOW UP TO
COMMITTEE I'M NOT MISTER
MCGUIRE. IS WHO WE ARE WAITING
ON IN THE MEANTIME MADAM.
SECRETARY IF YOU CAN. I HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AND A
SECOND BY MISTER OBERNOLTE IT'S
LIKE THE ALL REPUBLICANS ARE.
IF YOU CAN READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
ONE SB ONE SIXTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE FIVE A. SEVEN FIVE TWO TWO
FIVE SIXTY SIXTY ONE SIXTY SIX
SIX SEVEN SIX SEVEN TWENTY SIX
ANSEVEN EIGHTY. ALL RIGHT
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
ALL RIGHT KEEP CAN IT NOW IF
WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO
DISCUSS THE OUR LIST THE BILLS
THAT ARE BEING MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WHERE AUTHORS
HAVE WAIVED PRESENTATION MADAM
SECRETARY. SB 1-513-409-5460.
EIGHT SIXTY NINE SEVENTY TWO
ONE THREE SEVEN ONE THIRTY NINE
ONE TWO THREE ONE FIFT
691-821-9205.TWO NINE TWO TEN
TO ELEVEN TWO FORTY SEVEN TO
FIFTY THREE TO FIFTY EIGHT. TO
FIFTY TWO TWO SIX SIX TO SIXTY
EIGHT TO EIGHTY TO EIGHTY FIVE
THREE OH TWO THREE
984-741-4416 425-440-2440 FIVE
FORTY NINE. FOR FIFTY THREE
FORTY FIVE FOUR SIXTY EIGHT
FOUR SEVENTY TWO FOUR NINETY
THREE FIVE .
THIRTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE FIVE
FIFTY EIGHT FIVE SEVEN SIX.
1-315-886-0360 SIX OH NINE.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THREE SIX
SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT AND SEVENTY
FIVE. SO IF YOU ARE HERE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO ONE OF THE BILLS MOVED TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE WE WILL DO SO
AT PUBLIC COMMENT I'M SORRY
WE'RE NOT THERE YET I JUST
WANNA LET YOU KNOW YOU'LL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY BUT MISSED
MCGUIRE DID COME AND HAS ONE
BILL BE FORCED AND I'D LIKE TO
DISPENSE OF THAT FIRST. SO
MISTER REQUIRE SB FIVE TWENTY
THREE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. MUCH MY DOCTOR
QUIRK IN A SECOND BY MISS KOREA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ADVENTURE
GOOD TO SEE YOU IN GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE VERY QUICK THEN
SHARED I SP FIVE TWENTY THREE
REQUIRES ELECTION OFFICIALS AND
NOTIFY VOTERS IN MRS SIGNATURES
AT LEAST EIGHT DAYS PRIOR TO
CERTIFICATION OF AN ELECTION
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
VERIFY THE SIGNATURE AND
CORRECT. IN THE CHALLENGES OF
THE SECRETARY OF STATE WHO IS
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL HAS
NOTED THIS WILL NOT RESULT ANY
ADDITIONAL COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT IN REIMBURSABLE COST
FOR COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIALS
FOR POSTAGE AN ADMINISTRATION
IS MINIMAL HERE TODAY IS THE
AMAZING TIFFANY MARK. SHE IS
CHIEF OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR THE OFFICE SECTOR STATE
AGAIN MANAGER THINGS WE WORK ON
THIS ONE THANK YOU. TIFFANY
MARK ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY
STATE AL EXPEDIA AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT AND. PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS. OPPOSITION. SEE
NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
FINANCES OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT MAY CREATE A
NEW ELECTION RELATED
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE IT DOWN. THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
FINANCES THIS ISSUE IN THINKING
MANAGER SURE GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE NOT MISSED
BONTA IS HERE IS GABRIEL'S HERE
OKAY AT MR GARCIA IF ANYONE
KNOWS WHERE MR GARCIA'S I NEED
HIM TO ACTUALLY COME. TO
COMMITTEE TO VOTE SO. THAT'S
FINE. ALL RIGHT SO A BILL
CANNOT GET OUT UNTIL MISTER
GARCIA. SHOWS UP SO MR HELL
WOULD BE VERY DISAPPOINTED IF
WE DON'T GET HIM HERE WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON BILLS THAT WERE MOVED TO
SUSPENSE I WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE THAT THERE IS NO
PRESENTATION SO THE WAY WE
ALLOW THIS IS IF YOU SUPPORTER
POSE A BILL PLEASE TELL ME THE
BILL NUMBER IT HELPS IF YOU
TELL ME THE AUTHOR IN IF YOU
WANT TO SPEAK ON THE BILL OF
YOUR WHEN THE FIRST TWO PEOPLE
YOU'LL TWO MINUTES IF NOT
PLEASE JUST A- SAY YOUR NAME
AND POSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR JENNIFER BAKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS HAVE BEST BEFORE SIXTY
EIGHT BY CENTER JACKSON WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE WHICH WOULD BROUGH
BRING FISCAL TRANSPARENCY I'M
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVER RIGHT
TO SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
EXPENSIVE TAX CREDITS AND TAX
EXEMPTIONS IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
WILL CREATE A BORE THE UC WOULD
CONDUCT RESEARCH AND THE BOARD
THAT'S CREATED WHAT COMING INTO
THE I JUST READ. THIS BEST TAX.
TENSION THAT FOR YOU SURE. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR IN MEMBERS
LOSE MY DAY WITH CALIFORNIAN BE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF CENTER WHITE
HOUSE HE'S SB THIRTEEN. ALL THE
AUTHORS OF THE EIGHTY YOU BILLS
ARE WORKING VERY HARD INCLUDING
MISTER BLOOM TO TIE THIS
TOGETHER. THIS YEAR WE'RE
STRONGLY SUPPORTING EACH AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT SPECIFICALLY
TODAY HAVE SB THIRTEEN THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
HAVING LUNCH REPRESENTING THE
WESTERN WOULD PRESERVES
INSTITUTE HERE ON IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIXTY EIGHT GALGIANI TREATED
WOOD WAYS IT'S A PROGRAM THAT'S
BEEN IN PLACE FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS. THE LEGISLATURE FUNDED A
STUDY THREE YEARS AGO TO LOOK
A THE PROGRESS OF THE PROGRAM
THAT STUDYCAME OUT EARLY
SPRING. WHO WORKED WITH THE
ASSEMBLY. YOU ASKED HIM
COMMITTEE TO WORK ON LANGUAGE
FOR THAT BILL. THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT FUNCTIONS VERY
WELL AND IF THIS PROGRAM ISN'T
RE AUTHORIZE YOU TO FALL TO A
HAZARDOUS WASTE DISPOSAL HAS A
MAJOR IMPACT ON THE STATE
OPERATIONS SUCH AS CALTRANS AND
PARKS. AND IT WOULD BE INCREASE
ILLEGAL DUMPING VERTICALLY
IMPACT ON RURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND IT WILL INCREASE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS BECAUSE OF
INCREASED TRANSPORTATION. COSTS
DUE TO THE LIMITED NATURE OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE LANDFILL
DISPOSAL. AND WE VERY MUCH WITH
A BRAT BROAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
OF. BUSINESSES AND INDUSTRIES.
THAT ARE IMPACTED BY THIS A
PARTICULARLY I RECALLED. ON THE
WINE INDUSTRY ETCETERA SO WE
URGE YOU TAKING THAT'S OFF
SUSPENSE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU I'M
GONNA REMIND FOLKS YOU CAN OF
COURSE YOU HAVE THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK WITH LIGHT IT. YOU MUST
KEEP IT TO THE FISCAL. AND YOU
BY NO MEANS HAVE TO GIVE US. A
BACKGROUND AND BILL IT REGISTER
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
WORKS AS WELL THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CHERYL GAS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL VERSUS CA XIN
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT. BY SENATOR JACKSON'S AND
ALL IN MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
FROM CTA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
ON BEHALF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SENATOR JACKSON'S SP
FOUR SIX EIGHT. ALSO LIKE TO
MAKE COMMENTS AS HE TO. LIZ BUT
THAT'S OF ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIXTY BY CENTER
JACKSON. ALSO HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO SIXTY SIX
BY CENTER LEYVA ANDI'S Là
COMPENSATIONS WE HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE FISCAL COST THAT THIS
WOULD HAVE ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WE WANNA LINE OUR AGREEMENTS
WITH THE ANALYSIS AND WE'RE
SAYS THAT THE FISCAL COST CAN
POSSIBLY IN THE MAIL BE IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
GENERAL FUND IMPROPER NINETY
EIGHT. RIGHT MICHAEL ANY OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LIKE A
CALIFORNIA ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIX EIGHT SENATOR
JACKSON'S BILL. AND WE WILL
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH CITY.
DANIEL CANDLE KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
USE ASSOCIATION. AND WE WILL
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS AS WELL WITH
A CTA PLEASE REMOVE FROM
SUSPENSEFUL THANK YOU. WE CAN
AYE JENKINS WITH IRAQI ST
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FARMERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB TWO OH NINE BY SENATOR
DODD AND ALSO SB TO SORRY SB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
STERN AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
WORK EQUITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF. SB SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. IN THE GARAGE ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIX EIGHT
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING WAY
RICHMOND CALIFORNIA HIM
FOUNDATION IN OPPOSITION TO SB
ONE FIFTY THREE. SB ONE FIFTY
THREE AS WRITTEN HAD REMOVES AN
EXEMPTION THAT WILL HAVE A
FISCAL IMPACT ON THE COUNTIES
AND THE FARMERS OF THE STATE.
TO THE TUNE OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IT HAS TO DO WITH
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH THAT IS
NOT BEING CONDUCTED BY OUR HIGH
AT UNIVERSITIES AND WE ARE
CURRENTLY BY LAW AUTHORIZED TO
DO THOSE. AND WE HAVE A LONG
TRACK RECORD I HAVE SOME
INFORMATIONAL SITE WOULD LOVE
FOR YOU TO HAVE ON OUR
BACKGROUND AND THANK YOU WE ARE
CAN. IN OPPOSITION TO SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY THREE. THANK YOU.
HI CHRISTIAN SEISMIC ON
OPPOSITION SB ONE FIVE THREE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA HEMP
FOUNDATION I'M A YOU UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA BERKELEY VISITING
SCHOLARS WELL AS A PHD
CANDIDATE AT THE- UNIVERSITY OF
BRITISH COLUMBIA. SB ONE FIVE
THREE LIMITS THE- DEFINITION OF
AGRICULTURAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTION WHICH WILL THEN
INHIBIT THE LAW ARE WILL CAUSE
THE LOSS OF KNOWLEDGE WHICH
WILL IT. BE TO INCREASE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND FOR SAYING
CERTAIN HEMP OR CANNABIS FIELDS
INCREASE IN COMPLIANCE SEEDS
AND A LACK OF COMPETITION WHICH
WILL SLOW THE GROWTH OF THIS
BURGEONING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. RIGHT SO
THAT WAS A SECONDS BEGUN SB ONE
FIFTY THREE IT SO NO.
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION SPEAKERS
YOU CAN REGISTER SUPPORT I'M
I'M ALSO WITH SB ONE FIFTY
THREE OPPOSING IT. I AM THE
REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEMP ASSOCIATION.
AND NARROWING THE DEFINITION
I'M OKAY WE HAD TO SPEAKER SO
YOU. BUT I DO NEED YOUR NAME
YOU CAN BLAME THE DELAWARE
THANK YOU. OPPOSED YES AND I AM
A PUBLIC. THANK YOU FOR THE
SAME REASONS EVERYONE ELSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU A GREAT
RALSTON CONCERNED PARENT
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR NINETY
THREE AUTHOR SENATOR JACKSON
THIS BILL IS PREMATURE AS
FEDERAL GUIDELINES ARE STILL
BEING FORMULATED THE FISCAL
COST OF IMPLEMENTATION WILL BE
WASTED AS AT THIS TIME DUE TO
THE PENDING REGULATIONS THAT
LOOK TO MAKE MAJOR SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE TIMELINE PROCESS
IS CURRENTLY THE BILL AS
WRITTEN DOESN'T COMPLY WITH
CALIFORNIA APPELLATE COURT
DECISIONS NAMELY CROSS
EXAMINATION CREDIBILITY IS AN
ISSUE LIVE HEARING SINGLE
INVESTIGATOR MODEL AND NUMEROUS
OTHER SECTIONS THAT WERE
RECENTLY. AMENDED CAUSING HUGE
COST TO DEFEND LAWSUITS
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS NEARLY
A HUNDRED CASES PENDING AND-
THIS WILL WORK OUT. CERTAINLY
MORE DISCO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AMANDA WITH CALIFORNIA. DUE
PROCESS ADVOCATES AND THIS IS
REGARDING JACKSON'S SB. FOUR
NINETY THREE WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES OUR. TEST ARE ALL
PUBLIC COMMENT THE BILL LONG
CALL SB SIX TWENTY FIVE MR
HILLS IT'S OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL WITH MISS PETRIE-NORRIS
AND MR MAIENSCHEIN MISSED
PETRIE-NORRIS NOT VOTING MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN VOTING NO WITH THAT
ALL BILLS HAVE DISPENSED OF AND
WE HAVE CONCLUDED OUR